[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what is happening weirdos this is
Melissa Rauch Rouch pouch as I like to
call her Melissa and I most recently
worked together on the upcoming reboot
or it's not a reboot it's a continuation
I guess of the original Night Court
which is also called night court but we
knew each other a long time ago on a
little show on a little ditty about Jack
and Diane called uh best week ever which
was one of my first gigs ever so we get
in ever which we get into as well and
but you also may know her from Big Bang
Theory or just comedy in general she is
a delight I'm so excited you guys are
here I really really loved this episode
and only a couple things to plug up top
first of all a thanks to every weirdo
that came out to the shows in Chicago at
the Den it was some of the best shows of
the tour I've really really loved my
weekend in Chicago so thank you thank
you thank you to everybody that came out
next up is San Francisco Portland
Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and Washington
D.C go to petehomes.com for tickets to
those and hopefully I'll be adding more
cities soon so petehomes.com if you want
to come come see about me what who
references the song Come See About Me
that is ridiculous if you like this show
despite its references to the oldies
song Come See About Me Why why not uh
try a pizza pick the best way to support
the show is to try one of our beloved
sponsors like our friends at mint mobile
this holiday season the best deal in
Wireless can only be found at mint
mobile right now when you switch to Mint
mobile and buy a three month plan you'll
get another three months for free at as
the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only mint mobile
lets you order and activate from home
with esim while saving tons on phone
plans starting at just 15 a month the
first time I read this I was like that's
a typo it's 15 a month you could be
saving so much money and the holiday
season is a wonderful time to maybe gift
a mint mobile thing the three months
three months free holiday deal is an
incredible time to seize the opportunity
mint Mobile's best offer of the year is
here for a limited time by any three
month plan and get three months free by
going online only with esim and
eliminating the traditional costs of
retail mint mobile passes those
significant savings on to you all plans
come with unlimited talk and text and
high-speed data data or data delivered
on the nation's largest 5G Network use
your own phone with any mint Mobile plan
and switch easily and effortlessly with
esim or if you need a new device for a
limited plan get six months of free
service when you buy a select device and
plan just so switch to Mint mobile and
get premium wireless service starting at
just fifteen dollars a month again guys
for a limited time by any three month
mint Mobile plan and get three months
free by going to Mint
mobile.com slash weird that's
mintmobile.com weird cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com weird and show your
support of the show the other Pete's
pick to mention here up top no surprise
that I'm wearing it for those of you
watching this on video this is my Apollo
neuro you guys know I am nuts about
Apollo neuro it's the gift we give most
frequently to kids to grown-ups uh I
absolutely love it it is a game changer
what is it it is a piece of wearable
tech that helps your body recover from
stress it can help you relax sleep focus
and be more productive it's like a
wearable hug for the nervous system
using touch therapy to help you feel
safe and in control I wear mine on the
wrist Val wears hers on her ankle I like
wearing it I like telling people about
it because it helps so many of my
friends Apollo Nero delivers gentle
soothing I would say even almost
sub-perceptual vibrations you don't
notice that it's doing it other than how
you feel that train your nervous system
to recover and rebalance after stress so
for example when I was just in Chicago
on the plane the whole time I just have
it rocking on relax and unwind there's
so much stress on your body the
pressurized cabin the up and the down
and the length of the flight having it
on relax and unwind the whole ride helps
me exactly relax and unwind but it's
just this little electronic reminder to
your body like relax
relax relax relax and helps you ease
into your situation so it sends those
vibrations that can help you with energy
and wake up you'll feel that one that
one is not sub perceptual it's like uh
espresso but on your wrist social and
open is a wonderful setting it's usually
what I have it on when I'm recording
podcasts like these clear and focused
has been shown to help combat some of
the symptoms of ADD ADHD rebuild and
recover incredible after a workout or
perhaps a trying phone call with your
parents meditation and mindfulness I
always say if it only helped you
meditate as deeply as it helps me
meditate I would I would be shouting it
from the rooftops but that's just one of
the settings but meditation and
mindfulness you don't even have to be
meditating to put it on that sometimes
I'll just put on that when I'm walking
around the park and I want to drop into
my body a little bit more easily relax
and unwind as I mentioned and sleep and
renew I sleep with it on the only time I
charge it is when I'm in the shower
that's all I really needs and when I
wake up in the middle of the night
sometimes for Leela or to go to the
bathroom to get back in bed push these
two by buttons it reruns the program and
lulls me back to sleep just as a sleep
kit as a sleep tool I guess I mean
Apollo is is absolutely worth it but it
does all of those things actually
training your nervous system to cope
with stress better over time the more
you use it the better it works and I
always like to point out this is not
sold in crystal shops this is hard
science it was developed by a
neuroscientist and board certified
psychiatrist who've been studying the
impacts of chronic stress in humans for
nearly 15 years and a positive effects
on sleep stress cognitive performance
and Recovery have been proven in
multiple clinical trials and real world
studies so this is not woo-woo this is
this is the real deal and I absolutely
love it you can get 10 off and show your
support of the show by going to
apollonuro.com weird that's APO llo
n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird for 10 off and
to show your support of this show
alright everybody enjoy Melissa Rouch
one of my favorite chats in a long time
she's a delight can't wait for you to
watch or listen hopefully both don't
watch this unmute it won't make any
sense
get into it if there's ever been a guest
that was right for the couch this is
perfect like you can like a lit like the
little baby bird you are yes
I've been waiting for that perfect
look at all the pillows you can have a
little fort see it's supposed to be like
a little sleepover
just what can you see of me this is
lovely very I don't mind it at all see
that's what I want we have a lot of you
can tell a lot about a person
like I watch Comedians in Cars Getting
Coffee just to see what they order for
breakfast ah I think that's like the
main thing I'm interested in like I
don't really care like what Steve
Harvey's favorite car is or you know
what I'm saying like that's fine brought
breakfast I want to know what he orders
I want to see how he orders it and
whatever it's not just Steve Harvey all
of them and with the guests on our show
I really like to see their relationship
to the Nissan Verano that's the name of
the couch oh I love that it's a Crate
and Barrel of Verano okay it sounds like
a car to me so I call it the Nissan
Verano how did I do this is it this is a
dream okay like no smoke no smoke blown
really I could have messed it up no no
one is wrong because I could have
perched
like when I go to meetings
or yeah a lot of times when they go to
meetings so I do like I sit on the edge
yeah I'm not sitting like this the whole
time which is very embarrassing as a
grown woman to be talking business and
just your legs doing a dangle like a
ventriloquist dummy
so I'm very awkward to meetings because
I'm often just perching on the edge
there's a I have a choice I could dangle
or just this is great being a Wii
because I'll tell you this yeah let's
get Scottish okay I when you pulled up I
I don't think when I think of you I
don't think of you as a as a very small
you don't person no I mean I know you
are but then I guess let's put it this
way every time I see you I go like
you're surprised it's more even more or
it's even less oftentimes see me in
heels too yeah and today I'm not even
that yeah but I like seeing regular
route thank you normal route thanks
how's your day today how are you feeling
today today like how's your morning it's
a good day yeah I was excited to see you
I'm excited to see you too so yeah I
think it's a it's a good day I I don't
like I woke up and felt just to just to
give you an example of how much minutia
I'm interested in
this is how safe you can I woke up and I
was like we traveled we were in New
Mexico with with Leela we brought Leela
and she's she's four now and it was the
first trip we've taken where it still
felt like a vacation because she slept
in one of the mornings and we were like
what is happening it was a real we
turned a real corner but then that's
great I'm 43. I mean Hollywood years I'm
27. I'm like is that even a thing
anymore ageless you are ageless
you're a boy forever
but you're a pan of Comedy oh Peter Pan
Holmes
did I just coin you in your name I think
you did panels we just dropped the Peter
just being homes but um I like just just
traveling just one little flight it's
like an hour and a half and I'll wake up
the next day and the altitude difference
and stuff and I'm just like I said Deval
this morning I was like I feel oppressed
like I just feels squished but then good
that's a good descriptor oppressed is a
good one like you just kind of feel
squished yeah yeah and that's how I was
feeling and then I had a little bit of
toffee and I had a magic mind I got one
out if you want it did I ever give you
this on this is not product placement
this is my favorite thing in the world
you absolutely don't have to drink it
although it is your size that looks like
just like you got a juice
you just wouldn't do it like a juice
store and got like a large juice I own
but I only eat tiny things to make me
feel like a normal sized person like
chicken wings that is perfect when you
go to Medieval Times they give you a
chicken wings let me ask you how are you
with these small jokes because I really
don't want you to feel uncomfortable so
it's my comfort zone it's totally my
comfort zone so this is this that has a
little bit of matcha 35 milligrams of
caffeine but it also has nootropics and
adaptogens you told me about this are
you into adaptogens just in general
because they're real game Challengers I
I gotta say because now they're coming
out with all
like doing pseudo wines with the really
yeah yeah Oh you mean like non-alcoholic
ones yeah yeah I've seen those Val likes
those I'm very interested I haven't
tried one yet they really make you I I
would recommend that pre-pod it's nice
but you certainly don't have to okay
yeah don't feel you can just put it
there and take it with you if you don't
but here's my only concern yeah because
I'm very drunk
already Stoned Out of My Mind you also
seem very alert and ready to go so maybe
you don't need it it's only because I'm
excited to see you but love because I
have
um deal with this eyes little eyes we
talked about that so jacked on caffeine
on caffeine I've cut out caffeine
because I will Color Me embarrassed
because I offered you one of those on
set and you said the same thing but like
you're very sensitive to caffeine yes
because you're a wee one yeah and didn't
used to be I thought I'd built up my
tolerance in my 20s yes and now since I
cut it out if I have like a green tea I
will be I'll talk a mile a minute you
will not want to hear I believe it what
it what let me ask you this then because
we did do a show maybe we can't even say
I don't know what we could say we can we
can say night evening Court Night Court
Night Court I call it Night Court oh can
you tell us I just wanted trash is here
Katie sorry thank you please and thank
you
Zone because you're such a great
performer you're wearing 17 sombreros
and you would always show up consummate
professional what is your what is your
routine if it's not getting jacked on
caffeine interesting like what are you
doing are you exercising are you
meditating are you trying are you just a
momentum person like thing to think the
thing to think and you like staying in
that like upbeat such a good question
deal with it um just deal with it
um I used to be I need to get back into
a minute I used to be like
whole like two times a day meditation
girls same same every time I do it I go
oh this is the best why am I why don't I
not do it exactly that's what Val and I
said constantly yeah and I it's so true
whenever I go back to it I'm like oh
this is everything my brain is recharged
my I feel great I think it's because
it's called meditating which sounds like
mediating you know it's not a good word
it's snuggling with infinity that's
better you do it all day
with the Lord
right I try to I try to say like
recharging is a better way to put it
that is good relaxing yes like active
relaxing oh that's good pre-kids I was
so good so good about it and I think I
am terrible with any sort of like me
time yeah so I I need to get better
about that I saw that that you're a very
you're a helper person like you like
helping you like engaging and like
getting getting involved like in all
these beautiful ways and didn't we talk
a little bit about that on set that you
do maybe maybe not struggle but like you
don't necessarily take care of yourself
first you're like number nine yeah that
is your number one on the call sheet at
Night Court you're number nine on the
life call shoot that's true a lot of
people you really need to get better
about it well do you I mean are you okay
are you feeling fine and I'll say I need
to get better about it but I will you
won't no that's a false promise yeah I
think I
um
like if if it's focused on me I think
it'll cause me more anxiety
it's a way of deflecting yeah by the way
deflecting doesn't mean like avoiding
like don't look at me I'm disgusting you
just you're more comfortable serving
than yeah I think I have like a um
I'll worry too much about the people in
my life if I feel like all attention
isn't
um like that everyone's needs aren't met
does that make sense it does make sense
it is unique right I mean I'm I'm gonna
relate I'm a little bit that way I like
to receive attention I need attention we
all need attention I don't mean even in
the Razzle Dazzle show business but I
want it on my own terms like I'd like
that's why I like stand up and it's like
I will be the center of attention at
this time for 15 minutes that's good the
rest of the time depending on my mood
old PD it's a roll of the dice sometimes
it's real like introverted not not like
necessarily grumpy but it can be a
little bit grumpy and then there's other
times when I'm dropping liloff at school
and I'm hugging everybody and flipping
the kids and stuff like I don't know
which one's gonna show up that's
interesting but I like comedy because it
goes like be the attention person now I
wonder do you benefit from having a job
that gives Melissa a little attention
that's really I never thought about it
but you're absolutely right because it's
a safe and good way to get it yes and I
feel like I'm exactly the same way the
control of like on my own terms yes I
because I obviously I love performing
and that was always as a kid I was a
super shy kid
um so that was sort of my way of
expressing myself like you said in a way
of I can control this yeah versus like
on the plate like I was a weird kid who
on the playground like I was like can I
do an impression for you like that was
my way to make by the way when Winston
sees that I'm projecting on to you let
me just without getting your husband
into this when Val sees doughy red-faced
Little Pete and she loves him so much
she never got to meet him but as you
were saying that I was like I love
little Melissa so much related so much
to like not sweaty bad but like I was
like that too I wanted to I wanted to
send out little sonar pings and be like
this is what elf sounds like to me do
you hear him this way yeah notice I
wanted a little specialness I wanted a
little recognition exactly identity yes
like show and tell is like oh I could do
a Titan here you are killing and that
was like I was so excited for my show
until day but then I would be like just
a Wallflower yes
I completely get it it's like bursts
yeah it's like Nitro bursts yeah like
you can do it and then the rest of the
time you're kind of I'm a real empath
I'm absorbing a lot I get the more older
I get the more I realize like I'm
overwhelmed all this is like code for
like kind of an overwhelmed person just
kind of going like jeez there's so many
faces in this room and different volumes
and like they just misunderstood them
and and that would like charge me or
pull the bow back the string back on the
boat and then when it was my time I
razzled as a Razzle and then you go back
to recharge mode I'm interested that you
were shy though because it wasn't here I
read that your butt Mitzvah was
Melissa's comedy I love that you read
that I read it all definitely amazing no
did my mother write the buy over me I
mean your mom might be logging onto
Wikipedia and adding a few things that
is very true tell me where that because
when I read that I I melted I I died
tell me you already knew you liked
comedy you're 13 years old yes and you
already knew you liked comedy even
though you said you were shy and weird
yes
I think okay so I remember my first
laugh was oh my God six years old six or
seven watching Three's Company
and my parents being like you need to go
to bed and I did a Don Knott's
impression for my dad no like just like
to stall to go to bed and I started
imitating Mr Furley and my dad who's not
like a huge laugher like stopped in his
tracks
huge belly laugh and then I didn't go to
bed and so every time threes and I was
like what is this laughter at what I'm
doing and then that became my obsession
like I was obsessed with TV so then
watching whatever shows we were watching
at the time Jack hey on227
um I remember thinking like I never had
I think the gender gap was hard for me
to get over maybe or I didn't think it
was appropriate or something but I
remember being like I bet I could do
that voice interesting I mean she was
brilliant yeah of course and so I was
just entranced by her so that was like
picking out people to imitate and then
I I couldn't like get my hands on a
talent show in like the middle of New
Jersey and I just wanted to do it
because I was watching Star Search
yes obsessed obsessed and I saw someone
doing St like a stand-up of
impersonations I mean like what is this
job yeah you just stand up there make
people laugh yes and then they reward
you and there's a drum roll four and a
half stars and you're like exactly what
people keep telling me to shut up
totally and they're getting starred like
this is Stars and money yeah I forget
what the prize was twenty thousand
dollars or something that sounds right
big deal and all that I was like they're
instantly famous and kind of at the time
you sort of were in the 80s if you were
on Star search big deal bigger than like
big deal there was a kid dance Duo I
still remember their names Heinz and
Keisha oh I know Heinz and Keisha I'm
just kidding they did this podcast
Keisha yeah
I seriously like my heart would be
racing so hard if I if you told me he's
in case you're walking through that door
love need yes the heroes of our
childhood because you saw them on star
sign I saw them on Star Search my
brother and I would imitate that they
did an amazing dance Duo together and we
did we still like when we get together
our parties were like Heinz and Keisha
and we will do like the lips and no yeah
is your brother a similar stature he is
because I really want to picture him
exactly her size he is he he he's the
tallest one in my family I think at five
five or something okay yeah yeah so your
belly laughing dad is also a lady man a
wee man probably like five and a half
and wow maybe his feet were dangling off
the couch I am dead and I love that you
remember it and you said your dad's not
a good laugher sometimes I've heard it
said that the recipe for talent is had
to have one parent who gives you all of
the love and have one parent that's a
little bit harder interesting you can
say withholding yeah that was certainly
true in in my house my mom still is just
a TCBY Soft Serve All She all she gives
is is premium black and white ice cream
constant love and my dad is just a
little harder to impress I don't want to
say he's not loving yeah but if you make
if I make my dad left I made my dad
laugh once recently I figured out how to
make my dad left when I was like 40.
what's the way in do an impression of
him it's the only way in fact I'll say
that's the only way it's not a way
so I'll put on his clothes I put on his
hat and I'll cut this is me to be honest
I was probably like 35 or something okay
and I I would go you can do a deep dive
on I'm telling the listeners if they
want to see it it's on my Instagram many
years ago but I would go up to my dad
and be like Bill Belichick was a [__]
God and he just starts dying lamp so I
took a screen grab of that Instagram and
framed it that's how much it still still
a baby boy that's incredible still
wanting Papa
always always
chasing it that's what I'm saying but
didn't did do you feel that that was
sort of good because then you went into
the clubs and oh my God there's Papa he
splitted the 75 drunk people but it's
still focused it's always and if it's
Mom TV taping yes Night Court audience
that's Mom totally a thousand percent
Comedy Club coming up yeah it's it's
Papa all the way to Mama that is so true
that is so true and you know my parents
would come to I mean they started coming
to my open mics like they did they are
so Uber supportive it's crazy even
though still harder to impress I mean
all the bringer shows front and center
wow unbelievable but still watching him
in the front row like
he was like that yeah but not as big
yeah probably analyzing it yes I I
couldn't do that my dad surprised me and
showed up I just did the Wilbur in
Boston and he showed up even though I
literally and this is sort of it's not
sad I'm worried it's gonna sound sad I
tell my parents I forbid you to come you
can't come okay different Dynamics got
it got it I'm trying to be
grown man I want to be free I don't want
to be afraid yeah and I want to make fun
of them and I want to joke around and
yeah there's dirty stuff and whatever it
is but it's really like my dad's energy
is so big to me he really is like a like
a monolith or something okay that I
don't feel like there's room for me if
he's if he's there as well like yeah
yeah it's it's it's weird it's hard to
still get that but you did the opposite
you were doing your bringer show so
bring her shows for people that don't
know you had to bring how many like
usually between like what like seven and
it could be upset I never had seven
friends so I never did one I would have
done one yeah like I was above it I
think second paying guest by the way is
500 yeah and it's like you're I was in
college at the time when I started so I
went through my dorm like with everybody
everyone thing I mean it was a good
thing I was in college but still like
you're asking college kids like cough up
a two drink minimum and yes yeah and if
even if you get Cokes which we all did
because there were certain mics in New
York that you'd have to get two drinks
get two cokes suddenly somehow you're
paying with tip yeah 12 bucks or
something yeah you're like I didn't have
12 bucks I just ate [__] I just ate [__]
in front of five other comedians paying
attention they didn't even drink the
second Coke I used to try and talk to
that we were reminding me I was like can
I just give you the waitress can I just
give you five bucks yeah like I actually
knew somebody that when they did
Bringers they would um a good a Spam
risk is calling me twice my phone is on
do not disturb now it's off
thank you spam risk for calling back oh
I got his voicemail he doesn't want to
hear from me it's gonna need to hear
about this light bulb deal
um or let's be honest it's going to be
in
a foreign language I get a lot of
foreign
can we just have a moment of silence for
all the sweet floral nightgown grannies
I'm that get a call that are like this
is Amazon you bought a three thousand
dollar drone call us now and you can
cancel it why wouldn't they call it they
grew up in a time where you could get
cream on credit at the grocery store
I'll get you next time they trust
everybody of course and now they're
gonna lose their hands really like mourn
for future me because I know what's it
gonna be that I will be I mean you and I
are gonna be so confused so we're not
confused now I am confused now no [__]
and I'll put on whatever Zuck is having
us where put on some sort of visor and
then I'm gonna see if I can Robert
Redford dressed as the natural because I
know deep in my psyche there he is and
he's like Wonder Boy says you owe me 30k
and I'm like I do and I'm going to be
bankrupt and my kids are going to be
like what an idiot he didn't know the
natural spam
spam don't come in a mile away totally
it's happening to me we were talking
about your parents and it sounds like
your dad was was loving and kind and
coming to the shows just a little bit
harder to please I don't want to put
words so that gave you that thing they
came to your Bringers but but way before
that when you were 13 tell me about the
Batman okay so leading up to that you
got your first laugh got my first laugh
then there was
um after the star search looking for a
talent show there was a um beauty
pageant that came to town was not a
child who should be entered in a beauty
pageant it was a Cinderella scholarship
pageant I believe and they I got the
brochure and I was like the I saw on
their talent competition it's very
similar you entered because you wanted
to do that when I think forgive me if
I'm wrong but I feel like a lot of the
times it's like I'm beautiful oh God
damn it yes
and I was wearing the dress that I wore
for my uncle's wedding I'm dead and like
no teeth and my mom said if I saved up
my money like she would meet me halfway
and if I paid for half she would pay for
half so we did it how much was it
um I don't remember but enough that you
were enough that I was because I I think
she knew I would embarrass myself so she
was like I'm gonna she was trying to
stop you trying to stop if you can get
250 dollars
let's go let's go let's go oh [__] it
was terrible but she was my parents are
wildly supportive like if I had told him
I wasn't going into this business I
think they would have been like my dad
as reserved as he is was like there's no
job security anything he's a CPA like
very by the book
um but had a lot of job losses over the
year from company downsizing so he was
very much like follow your dreams
there's no job security anything which
is amazing that's beautiful by the way
really great one of my favorite lines of
office space where they go They're you
know they're working at in attack and
they don't like it and they go he's
trying to say we need to get out of here
and he goes can you imagine if we're
doing this in 20 years and then one of
the guys goes like it would be awesome
to have that kind of job security and
you realize that there is it's a it's a
myth it's like doing something that
sucks doesn't guarantee you're gonna get
to do it that is so true I forgot about
that one so your dad knew that my dad
knew that so he was very very as with my
mom
um so I did this I did the talent
competition which was me doing
impressions and that was like I'm hooked
I'm a comedian I am and you did all of
it I did yeah I did I mean was there
like walk catwalk okay yeah and I didn't
know like you see me on the video like
just walking around a circle and like
someone be like on this side of the
stage on this side of the stage oh my
God that's how old six or seven six or
seven Rouge pounds yeah also I'll see if
I can find it yeah oh my God yes please
is done no it's not yet not yet not your
moment yes and they and it was like a
weekend like a full weekend like each
day was another so like I like waded
through the like dress wear and then
there was a sportswear and my mom was
like I remember sitting here in the
office just like
so God bless her mortified that I was
going to and but she was also for when
they came time to Talent day she was
like and they didn't really know what I
was gonna do your parents are yeah my
parents I kept on saying I was going to
do Impressions and stand up but I hadn't
really showed it yeah and then you're
like getting good 10-year jump on Dave
Chappelle like I'm six let me do it
um and they and that was it like I
remember like I still remember the
judges and their faces when they were
laughing because I was so because I had
only done something it worked and I won
the talent competition of course he did
what was what was number two a woman
because they were all like pageant kids
like really great okay so you smoked
some some real guns it was because I was
I was and I'm saying this and not a way
to brag it was so weird what I was doing
was so weird I thought you're gonna say
unbearably cute it stood out though it
was weird like I remember the judges
looking at each other look that you get
as a kid when
you're old enough to know that people
are
they're not they're like confused by you
yep and I remember seeing that look like
the judges looking at each other and
laughing but being like what is this
what is this and so it really was like a
winning out of this is the weirdest
thing we've ever seen in Suburban New
Jersey and it had to have been good too
I mean what Impressions did you do
started with Mr Furley and everything
was like you're Classic you opened with
the big hip yeah original that was like
my my original joke so it was very much
like
um my next impersonation is going to be
Mr Furley from Three's Company and then
I take a minute
um next impersonation is going to be
um and they it was a lot of just I
remembered the other moms like the faces
on the other moms just like kind of
giggling and I remember that also like
they're not laughing with me
oh like I remember clocking that but
then looking at the judges who are
actually laughing with me and my parents
beaming like that my dad just doubled
over with pure Pride you got all three
you got the laughing in the wrong way
which still hurts my feelings it's not
okay I'm like no really occasionally I
wouldn't I'm not sure about that okay
I'm gonna check myself okay I think I
already wrecked myself but I'm gonna
check myself out of this tracking okay
which a lot of people don't know you can
do you can do it you can check yourself
at any point you can it's nice to do it
before you wreck yourself but even if
you wreck yourself just go ahead and
check yourself hey why did I just wreck
myself you know what I actually think
it's better to do a post check after a
wreck yes right it's the best time to
check after Iraq prereq that's how
you're gonna grow it's like I don't make
kids you don't learn without wrecking no
so until you're 40 go ahead and check
yourself after you wreck yourself I
agree I agree otherwise you're not gonna
you're not gonna learn nothing happens
no gross just just consistently wreck
yourself that's right that's the first
28 years yes it's like going on a bad
day and you're like let's just say he
was constantly checking himself before
he wrecked himself I could have used a
little bit more wreck then check if you
know what I mean
um okay love need uh where were we your
dad oh you got all three kinds of laughs
I was sharing myself before I wrecked
myself I just I know that kind and I'm
glad you're six years old and you're
seeing that that's one of the ways it
can go yeah is that like it's almost
worse than a bomb not not to impose a
thousand percent or hurt than it needs
but it's like oh they they're like
pitying me or something yes but the
judges where it counts are laughing and
your parents are beaming yes can't
believe this like I I actually would
love to because this judge I she was
like uh I think a former Beauty
intestine herself
um and she she was such a classy lady
like I could picture and it was like the
classiest lady I've ever seen anything
can I say in the 80s was like Peak
classy lady classy I don't see them like
that anymore they I don't know that
they're they exist and like the
Maybelline ladies
this woman had a sharp crisp White
Collar under a Blazer like I pictured
her you know in like all those 80s
movies like if someone was classy and
fancy or also a villain they would just
have like one piece of sushi on like a
white plate for lunch yes dead and
that's like always mineral water yes in
a wine glass exactly like a stark white
kitchen and that's what this woman was
to me
yes eating it very deliberately
and I picture One String of Pearls yes
very classy now I feel like all the I
feel this way about the men too like I
thought um what's his name uh Donald
Glover was great as Lando Calrissian but
when I look at uh Lando in the early
Star Wars I'm like that's a [__] man
and now I feel like every me included we
all look like kids I I don't I when I
talk about this a lot of like I still
don't feel like I'm like oh when am I
going to be cooked yes when am I gonna
walk in a room and people will be like
oh a [__] man is yeah and I'm not
talking about uh masculinity like an
adult I just mean like look at a
photograph and go there's an adult right
because Donald Glover's a [__] adult
but when I saw him in that thing I was
like just too small or something like
Billy just had like a man stash or
something and Donald had a mustache too
like it just looked different in the 80s
and is it because like that's
interesting I do
is it because like they're of our gen
like are we not seeing it it has to be
like how your SNL when you were a
teenager that cast is always going to be
your favorite cast yes and those
grown-ups are always going to be your
grown-ups because for sure as we're
talking there's some eight-year-old
that's looking at Donald Glover and
being like when am I gonna look like a
man and I'm like we all look like we
rode our bmx's decide like I sometimes
wonder when like kids look because I I
think I often confuse kids because I
think when they first clock me they're
like oh you're one of us yeah and then
and then they like walk a little more
and they're like yeah check our hands no
she won't eat the paste she's on she's a
grown-up yeah is she like and I even so
I I often wonder like what that is for
like when they're I don't think anyone
would ever there's no point in my life a
little Melissa would look at me and be
like there's a classy lady yeah that's
right it's never never and when I think
of my mom wearing like a chunky amber
necklace and like a white stiff shirt
with a sweater over it I'm like there's
a [__] that's a woman that's a woman
yeah and Val and I go out to dinner I'm
like I can't believe they didn't give us
kids menu it's like we should be chicky
thingies over here sure Wednesday when
like because we start we got together
when we were 19. so like whenever we
would go into Russian like and they
would give us like a crappy table we'd
always be like they're they're totally
treating a shitty because we look so
young yeah and now we've been together
for over 20 years wow and Winston
recently was like I think that and I was
like we can't use that excuse anymore
they're not they're just we're getting
shitty treated it just happens yes
because sometimes you get shitty treats
yes sometimes you really are the person
but I think we'll be doing that at 80.
like I think we'll still be like and
you'll be even smaller I will I am so
scared I'm just going to shrink into
nothing you're going to be a little Mr
Peanut I am I'm Thumbelina I don't need
a retirement plan I'm just gonna get a
matchbox I'm just just tuck me away and
one match in there for safety that's in
case a moth comes by and you have to
strike it on the side of the box
out of here that's exactly what I'm
gonna say yeah of course that's my
emergency department okay we're on our
way you were six you killed it did that
we're building up to the you're hooked
now what do you do you have a good seven
years until you're right so then just
obsessed with comedy in every form like
um
really got into the care like old
episodes of The Carol Burnett Show so
like on that side of things
um was very into Robin Williams stand up
yep for I remember watching that being
like how is this happening on a comic
relief yes like being so that was my
everything yes
um and
um I remember finding out that he had
set lists not in a bad way of course he
did but there was some I think it was
I'm embarrassed it might be the book how
to be a working comic which I do not
recommend wait that's who wrote that
it's like Dave scholarships like this
and like I remember poor guy David thank
you for writing that book it was great
but there was a part where he wrote
about one of his own bets and he was
like and that was just a life thing and
I got a killer bit out of it and I'm
like 12 and I'm like that's your killer
pen okay even at the time being like
just power moves did you really I
couldn't wait I actually want to bring
this back to YouTube because like when
we did the multicam that we were doing I
was like this is exactly what I thought
I would be doing like wow even though I
love doing the single cams and stuff
that felt really cool and I would love
to do it again for sure the multicam was
when I was like 12 year old Pete
is so happy that this is real show
business do you relate to that a million
yes like a million times over that was
I remember seeing like when whenever a
sitcom would end they would sometimes
show them all how they would come out
for bows yes on tape night or the finale
of Cosby Show where they dance off the
stage I was like that's what it looks
like
craziness that and that I still I still
actually and I know this may sound very
Pollyanna but like I walk onto a sitcom
set and I can't I I need to take a
minute even the stress of everything
like yeah it's
there's a magic there I you go in the
fridge and there's a thing called beer
it just says beer on it I'm like I've
done it I've made it I made it to where
the beer is yeah like beer brand beer
there's nothing that I love more than a
prop food to remind me of the the
experience of where I am I'm dead and
the prop department just flying in like
a clean plate of fries this sounds like
I want to be doted on that's not what it
is I love that there are almost like
carnies in the good way like just like
theater magic magic of what that is and
getting to to actually see behind that
that curtain and the mix of you and I
who since we were six years old were
like Razzle Dazzle them you know and
also guys that remind me of my dad like
the union guys that build the sets and
strike the lights and all that sort of
stuff so you have this like Confluence
of flavors it's not all just like razzle
dazzle with sparkly hats and stuff it's
also a guy with a cigarette that's like
Melissa they need you on set like that
is fun I'm like this is it it's fun it's
all here it's true and there's some
there is like the multi-cam and I being
on single accounts too you get that of
course you're like I'm in Show Business
wonderful
um but they're doing a multi-camp
there's something because you look up
there's no ceiling yeah yeah and you're
there it's true some people get sad I
didn't mean to cut you off but yeah like
when you're shooting a single game
you're in an apartment yes it's just a
real apartment yes and you're shooting
it that's fine when we I would read the
Night Court scripts and there'd be like
some swing set like a set that would
only be used one day and they just build
like on how we roll that just build a
baseball card shop yeah and I'm like
where the [__] did this come from and it
looks I'm not saying it looks like you
could trick me you know blindfold me and
take me there and I'd be like I'm in a
baseball card but it looks like a TV
baseball card shop like it looks like a
shoot this way it'll look like a
baseball card isn't that amazing I love
it so much they build it in seconds yes
and they take it down even the
impermanence of it Delights me it's like
and this will be gone yeah this is gone
where did they we had a scene that was
in a funeral home and they just brought
in caskets I'm like you're telling me
somewhere on the Warner Brothers lot
there's just stored caskets it's it's
unbelievable or a bowling alley or
whatever and the answer is yes yeah
that's what all those big Animaniac
buildings are yeah it's filled with
barber shops Warner Brothers water
towers
it's overflowing with cowboy hats
giant toothbrushes we'll get a boa it's
in there you got me really excited
forgive I talk too much no I love it hit
it
yes and still like I pushed because I
was still like looking for my fix so
then I a few more beauty pageants and
then as I did I did but then I started
like as I got older
I really like my adolescent was awkward
like especially like the tween into like
that was the cute at that point I didn't
even have that saving me
um you mean you had awkward years oh big
time Big this explains a lot yeah it was
friends a lot really really awkward
um you two oh my god when I say rayon
shirts and sweaty and I base my hair on
Zach Morris so it was like spiky in the
front but like I'd comb it down and it
was rock hard I was wearing cologne wait
why at what age and what this is like
seven of course it was your car Noir
don't even ask what it was and of course
I got like the dracarnore soap like this
did the sunflower
just on those old Pharmacy things with
all the dots in it yeah no did they have
to unlock it
um oh [__]
[__] what oh no that she's just telling
me it's been I was trying to I was gonna
look at my clock time is flying it's
been 40 minutes we're gonna come back to
what okay amazing 12 15 12 20. okay all
right still this is perfect for a mid a
mid roll okay
um when we come back we're going to talk
more about being dorks and of course
we're going to get into all the regular
stuff
when we come back it'll be more of this
great we'll be right back 60 seconds
pardon the interruption weirdos this
show this episode is brought To Us by
our friends at mizzen in Maine look I
changed I threw on my missing and Main
dress shirt which I absolutely love I
don't know if you know this I'm not a
huge fashion person but of course I want
to look good and I want to be
comfortable and I don't want to devote
my entire life into the pursuit of
finding these things so luckily I found
mizzen in Maine which ticks all of those
boxes when I am touring I want to be uh
first of all I want to pack as little as
possible so I can ideally just go with a
carry-on so I often am wearing what I'm
going to wear on stage on the plane the
problem with that is dress shirts are
usually stiff hard unforgiving and
uncomfortable but you gotta wear it on
the plane and it just doesn't feel right
missing in Maine has entered to save me
from this problem it's comfortable
enough to wear on a plane and looks good
enough to wear in front of hundreds of
people when I'm performing which is
incredible I'm tired of my old stiff
dress shirts I want to look good on on
camera I want to look good on stage and
I am a huge huge fan of mizen and Maine
you got to check them out they are the
inventors of the performance fabric
dress shirt is in the main combines the
comfort and flexibility of your favorite
athletic wear with the fit and style of
a custom dress shirt which means it's
lightweight it's breathable and it's
moisture wicking which frankly when I'm
on stage that's super important missing
and Mains close I will have you looking
great basically they make really
comfortable dress shirts that you need
to try to believe the first time I tried
it on I had never put on a shirt like
this that felt this good and looked this
good I can tell you firsthand that
missing and Maine's dress shirts are
actually the best dress shirts that I
have ever worn probably the best part is
that they are machine washable that
means no more expensive trips to the dry
cleaner Plus for the cold weather
they've got amazing flannels pants
sweaters and jackets made from that same
missing and Main material that they are
now famous for and if somebody uh if
somehow after all this you're still not
a Believer they've got over 30
000 five-star reviews so you know
they're making a great product so when I
was in Chicago flying there going on
stage wearing a nice shirt looking good
being comfortable missing in Maine
literally has me covered so if you wear
dress shirts and don't wear missing in
Maine let me tell you you're making a
huge mistake I have a bunch of their
shirts I have a bunch of their pants
missing in Maine is my go-to dress shirt
it's always such an inconvenience to go
to the dry cleaner I absolutely hate it
my clothes end up staying there
sometimes for weeks because I can't find
the time to go back so the fact that
these are machine washable are amazing
in and of itself that is enough but
comfortable and look great so if you
want the best cold weather clothing this
holiday season check out missing in
Maine it's a great gift or a gift to
give yourself right now if you go to
mizzen and Maine
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com
and use promo code weird you'll receive
25 off any regular price order of 130
bucks or more which means that's like 25
off when you go to mizzen and main.com
and use promo code weird
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d m a i n.com and use
promo code weird do yourself a favor
this show you made it weird is sponsored
by betterhelp you guys know that I am a
huge fan of talk therapy it's absolutely
transformed my life and changed it for
the better I often have wished in
especially in my 20s and 30s that I wish
that life came with a user manual uh
unfortunately it doesn't it doesn't come
with a manual so when it's not working
for you it's normal to feel stuck I
remember I first started going to
therapy here in Los Angeles because I
was going through a breakup and I just
needed help I needed guidance I couldn't
process it on my own and that totally
helped and changed my life because I
needed to get out of that relationship
navigating any of life's challenges not
just breakups can make you feel unsure
whether it's a career change a love life
or becoming a parent therapists are
trained to help you figure out the cause
of challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour for the complex engine called you
and betterhelp has connected over 3
million people with licensed therapists
it's convenient and accessible anywhere
because it's a hundred percent online it
is incredible to help with
self-empowerment dealing with trauma
dealing with uncopable feel unculpable
is that a word feelings or in my case
decisions that you need to make big Life
Changes having someone to talk to about
it is way more effective than the sum of
its parts meaning talking to someone
just seems like just talking to somebody
just spinning your wheels it's
absolutely not you need another person
there you need a trained person there
somebody who can listen and and guide
you gently through the biggest moments
of your life so as the world's largest
therapy service better help has matched
as I said three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking easy you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
couldn't be simpler and removes any
awkwardness that and speaking of
awkwardness no waiting rooms no traffic
and no endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
weirdo that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo do yourself a
favor give yourself the love and support
you need and show your support of this
show alright everybody let's get back to
Melissa
and we're back okay so your car Noir
soap and body wash or what I feel like
there were a bunch of different things
but I was wearing that slicked hair I
remember this is this is a vulnerable
memory but I remember in seventh grade
just sitting in the corner
saying my phone number oh what do you
mean
I'm so embarrassed were you saying it so
that people people I'm gonna write that
down yeah and call me because I was
again a child of Television so I thought
like girls having your number like right
it was totally misguided but I was going
eight six one eight nine oh nine solid
bit but then maybe took it too far just
went too long what would they think
they're gonna call no this is still the
age was it directed at anyone well yeah
there were certain I was in a small
school and there were only I feel like
there were only like five girls and five
boys that's probably wrong maybe eight
and eight oh wow but it was small wow so
everybody would pair off okay and then
there'd be like a few confirmed
bachelors and that was always me but
when was your first day yeah it was uh
Valentine's Day my senior year of high
school uh
sorry is that her
no please
no don't even don't do you want to check
it's not your it's not a not a no okay
#parent life
I've answered my phone on stage have you
been like I just need to make sure it's
not an emergency it's a total yeah it's
a different ball game I don't know what
I would do I guess I would leave I'd get
on a helicopter
was it emergency situations when you
answered it no no okay and then it's
always either way you win it's either a
funny bit that you touch with the phone
or it isn't a word that's not a good
situation but at least you were
available right that's true that's true
um yeah so small and and I but I I swear
to you Melissa Rauch I when I was in
seventh grade I I had the uh I wish
there was another example other than
Woody Allen I know that's a troubled
person but like I had the Woody
allen-ish perspective the neurotic
grown-up perspective of like interesting
what are we gonna date like I really was
like what are we gonna do I don't have
any money I don't have a car that's
amazing I'd watch say by the Bell and
they're all going to the Max and stuff
I'm like there's nothing Max there's no
Max so like on Valentine's Day senior
where did you go Bertucci's
that's I love Bertucci's little Olive in
the center that's amazing the pizza yeah
and all I remember from the date was
when the bill came and she was like a
feminist kind of woman and I remember
the bill came and I slapped it like I
couldn't wait to pay for it because
that's all I knew right like I'm gonna
be a gentleman I at least I'm gonna pay
the bill what did she say I just oh she
accepted it and was fine with it but I
wish I'd just been like you just don't
know yeah although again like that did
you was that like your girl did she
become your girlfriend was it just a no
oh
it's okay I remember she went to the
junior prom with someone else and went
to the senior prom with me she did go to
the senior program which was a big deal
and I've told the story before and she
she there were only three slow songs at
my senior prom three that's ridiculous
the rest of the time we're just like
you'll know how to dance it was so
awkward so there was a slow song came on
I stood up and ran looking for her
because I was sitting by the side of
course and I'm looking for her and she
was and she saw this other guy was like
Hey and she gave them this big hug and
then they danced and then I just like
walked away awkwardly
feet and they're married now what what
no wait you know you're married and
they're I think they're happy at least
in that that at least it was it wasn't
just anybody right it was who she should
have been at the prom
that's amazing I just like the slow
rotating hug that's a dance that I was
always more comfortable with and the
could when did your height kick in were
you I was tall then okay and then when I
got to college and I'm going to turn
this back around to you Roger pouch
because you are too delightful I don't
want to know because like the the
dancing you know when you oh yeah when I
got to college I remember like the
tallest girl in school asked me to a
dance but then I spent the whole dance
with this other girl who wasn't tall
poor tall person like where was I I just
went away
too shy again even in college I was like
really what are we gonna do like I just
had like that seinfeldy like I felt like
dating was for like people in their 20s
that have cars like a real person a real
person yeah kids I also like even though
I was like sexually awakened like
puberty I I just I wasn't like what
these people are like nine
there were two it was we felt like kids
they felt like a kid I love that you had
that perspective it was weird and then I
saw the other kids that were like nah
man yeah I'm going for it but you're an
old soul so you were like it was like
you were coming back again you're like
okay yes I've been here I gotta just
wait for the right time this is a waste
of time waiting for my real life to
begin the whole time I was like just you
and this is how I'm gonna put it back to
you because I bet this will spark
something I just couldn't wait to be an
age which is like 33 where you could be
a cop in a movie you could be a lawyer
in a movie you could be a husband a
father you know I mean like all of these
different roles I just wanted to be the
age where you could be anything instead
of the age where you can only be one
thing which is a Junior High kid that's
like right my pants like get the [__]
out of here but you were wanting to be
an actor yes wow and I used to and do
you relate to that I used to be in a
parking vivid memory I'd be in a parking
lot my parents and I had just had dinner
the whole family I'm just looking at the
parking lot thinking of the million
movies that you could shoot in this
parking lot and how perfect it was like
this railing and not even from a
cinematography standpoint just like
imagine when I have a car and a camera I
can come here and just shoot this yeah I
was trying to get back in touch with
that part of me the excite yes just the
Innocence yes you know so you you were
obviously that way too completely and
like my and it was always this like okay
we're gonna do it this way we're gonna
do things on at an amateur level now
until I get to do it for real because my
brother wanted to do it also so we would
just do shows in the basement like every
day afternoon camcord Big Time camcorder
um horror movies lots of horror movies
on the camcorder because my brother
loved them and then many dramatic turns
from me like
twists lots of twists me very much like
with the fans blowing in my face like no
no go away that style right over you
just here you know how they put a
brighter light over their eyes no oh and
I really and even at that age I was like
well I need to like I have to show that
I have this other side of me because I'm
letting everyone know like that I'm a
comedian they know I'm a comedian short
like Martin Short was like that yes I
remember yes my horror career to
overshadow my comedy career he would say
things like that when he was that age
yeah and you were that way too yes I
need to diversify totally I don't want
to be pigeonhole yes and very much like
because I everyone knew me quote unquote
for my Impressions
when we did the horror movies I was like
I have to show that I'm not just I'm so
much more than Impressions yes I could
do more so you were Kevin Hart when you
were 12.
I've been chasing it for my whole life
I'm still not yes but my brother was a
big influence because he was like my
first director and we would come home
every day after school and rehearse wow
I don't know like there was a he ran a
tight ship kids in the neighborhood
dropped off because they were like this
is too intense really because we had
like a company
it was called dancing Mania Productions
and we would do one musical a year
people got mad that I was always cast to
the lead I was like well it's my house
and my brothers
and we don't know the word nepotism
exactly so deal I don't even know what
I'm saying right now nepotism I don't
know what that means who taught me that
and he was so
I mean he was the Productions he would
put on like really like good production
value we did Grease and we had a toy car
that he spray painted
as grease lightning it was really great
wow yeah so that was very much like I
love that you had this partner he was a
one like the best like and so he's such
a like he's this he's a creative genius
so he would do these full-scale
Productions in my parents basement that
I got to be a part of wow and I would
just I really jumped on board it was
really him doing it that I was like I'm
gonna I hope this isn't weird it is the
name of the show but it's like I find it
fitting then that you fell in love with
Winston it was also creative because my
I love my brother-in-law he's hilarious
he's creative he would do all the stuff
you're talking about with Val so of
course she was drawn to a comedian you
know what I mean like and I was I love
that so like I see that yeah once you
have a silly Billy totally who says yes
and a partner and wants to do things and
isn't just embarrassed like I love my
brother to death but he was so
embarrassed we both kind of were yeah
it's a lot of embarrassment to get over
so when I met those those yes people you
just want more of it [__] kidding me
like I said do you want to do improv
games and you said yes and now we're
doing that yeah as opposed to again my
brother's done a lot of work and he's
changed he's he's a much more yes of a
person now a million times and we have a
great relationship but when we were I'd
say this if he was in the room when we
were like 15 and 13 and I was like I'm a
pirate he'd be like oh you know of
course yeah you just wanted to be cool
yeah and when did he when did that
change for him honestly recently I mean
he moved out here to do comedy and I
think when he saw how I'm not sure about
this but I think when he saw how uncool
comedy isn't cool it's like Steve
Martin's comedy isn't pretty it's like
it's also not cool it's not it's not
cool to eat [__] and like drive to a
biker bar in Peoria Illinois and do
badly that's not cool you see like Aziz
in his suits and private jet or whatever
it's like you think that's it and it's
not it's so much more like even on Night
Court we're like trying dumb stuff like
to see where it is that's not really
cool it's cool like I already know what
the thing is right like I was thinking
of your character on Big Bang is I
really mean this like what a bold choice
and I know how scary choices are that's
the opposite of cool what if you had
made that choice and people were like
Melissa what are you doing that's
humiliation that most people guard
against so firmly that they'd never even
that is don't you think there must be
there is a certain personality type that
I feel like goes into this
because it is it's a constant rejection
and a constant humiliation constant
let's go ahead and I feel like I like is
it is there a screw loose that you're
like I or is it a
you love it so much that you're willing
to sacrifice the embarrassment okay I'm
gonna go and because I yeah I could see
screw loose and be like and we it's
actually worse it's a screw that we
can't reach so we need someone else to
reaching so that's like the audience or
the director the writer or whatever I'll
give you that but I'll also give you Val
and I were just talking about this and
it's it'll blow your mind like it blew
my brain it's like most people would
rather avoid
um pain rather than pursue pleasure so
but what happens is I'll give you an
example you're in a tech not you you're
in a terrible relationship they want to
move to Phoenix and your families all in
Temecula I don't know I'm just saying
like you don't want to do it but it's
too painful to tell them no or stand up
for yourself or whatever it may be so
you avoid that short-term pain but then
it leads to 20 years of pain wow as
opposed to just getting one lump sum of
pain one afternoon one long weekend of
pain to avoid nine years of pain
similarly in comedy you eat [__] for 10
years you it's probably going to be
about 10 years
but then you get 50 years of being good
at comedy and and you avoid all of the
you you
it's like this
I don't want to call it wisdom because I
don't I didn't think I was doing it
consciously but there is a wisdom to it
it's like I know pain is part of this so
I'm going to control it and I'm gonna go
get it as opposed to waiting for it to
get me and just doing everything I can
to like Dodge The Matrix bullets yeah
and let some of them hit me because
every person that's ever lived tells you
that like the path is covered in Thorns
yeah thistles so I'm just gonna go
through the thorns and thistles now yeah
get my pain out of the way and then have
like my life is not that interesting now
it was all pain but so many people would
go like I'd like to do comedy but Open
Mic seem too painful yeah you're [__]
right you know what else sex 50 years of
wondering if you would have enjoyed it
or been good at it that is that's so
much more it's a beautiful way of
putting it that is so so true and let me
ask you something when you were going
through it when you were doing it
how painful did it feel is it now
looking back that you're like whoa that
was really hard it's more that yeah
because did you romanticize it even when
it was happening yes me too yeah I was
like big time like this so totally
but so like so excited by it I couldn't
believe that I was performing in New
York City same same wouldn't believe
that where the Subways were yes I was on
stage I couldn't agree more and near me
eating [__] was Jerry Seinfeld in my
mind he was somewhere out there
Chappelle was somewhere out there
absolutely and I'm in the same city
totally bought into all of it same and I
yeah it felt like I was so close to the
pulse of it even like in the back of a
hamburger restaurant where there was an
open mic I remember writing in my
journal like so excited and talking
about and this person got up and then I
did these jokes and documenting just the
excitement of that and I feel like
there's
um which really it obviously helps
that's the engine that keeps you going
is the fact that you're able to to
romanticize it and then you actually
like it you actually you're not
pretending to like it yes and this is
why well we haven't a good comedy chat
in a while but like on this podcast but
like the people that you knew were doing
it because they wanted to be rich or
famous or to meet sexual partners it
never it just didn't ring the same way
those were those weren't my that wasn't
my scene we were the we were the fruit
on the bottom yogurt boys you know what
I mean just like the weird lunchbox yes
I just mean like you open it up and you
smell their weird food and we're just
like we love comedy like that's that's
what was happening and like a lot of
those people became you know clean
wearing suits and selling out theaters
and stuff but like at the time you could
smell the people that wanted to be
Carson Daly Yeah a hundred miles away
that is that's very nothing wrong with
Carson Daley I'm just saying uh you know
what I mean like yeah like uh
celebrities chasing it for a different
reason yeah there is what is he he's a
pop figure what do you call Carson a
toast like
a host but like if like his job is to be
like famous I don't know yeah he is a
good host I'm not even [__] on him
I'm just saying like there are people
that are like I want to I think there's
more of an like there's an end gaming
mentality of like here is what I hope
this gets me as opposed to like I can't
believe you took me back to a Thai
restaurant where I'm like I went up yeah
was this a place I feel like
um on like 20 something street I was so
new to the city I couldn't even tell you
what neighborhood or what borough okay
like I just got there scared on the and
I don't mean to over romanticize it but
I remember being like does I'm trying to
get to Christopher Street because the
two that people would always help you
like you gotta get off here and take
that one and I remember and I tell
people this all the time I'm like if
you're from another city Jersey or
whatever that's your credit because I'd
be like I'm from I'm coming I'm fresh
from Chicago like that was like this guy
arrived by airplane
and like that was your Allure you're a
Mystique or whatever and then I realized
I was like I'd been doing comedy for
three years in Chicago and I'm like no
one here knows any of my bits so I'm
like I have seven five minute sets that
everyone's gonna think I'm like the most
prolific person I didn't realize that I
didn't realize you started there in
Chicago yeah yeah I was there for three
years and then and we got to talk about
this I moved to New York and I'm only
saying this to put it to you honest
honest to goodness
moved to New York with my ex-wife she
starts teaching his school I she very
graciously and you know it was we were
both in agreement no no straight job I'm
not gonna have a backup job like I'm
just gonna Focus 100 because I'm sort of
like a one thing a day person got it and
if I'm what a what a you have to get
over that for a lot of your life but now
I recognize that what I'm saying is I
know if I'm tired I won't go to a show
to just watch or I won't go to a mic
like I was just too gentle and like you
don't work in the morning right I can't
be out at 11. totally totally I was like
no job and then it was like
six weeks or something later Jesse Klein
saw me at rafifi and I emailed her and
and I got on Best Week Ever how did it
happen for you wow wait one question
were you so how long have you had you
been doing stand-up in New York before
there she saw you with that for Best
Week Ever by the way I'm not sure if it
was six weeks or maybe I feel like it
was less than two months for sure it's
amazing but like I was reading the what
is where would they list the mics and
stuff the village Village Voice and one
of them was like just Jesse Klein and
Nick Kroll roast The Happening it was
called Welcome to our week oh yeah and
it was like they roast the Hat I'm
picturing it like a studio like
and I get there it's just a bar and a
video store basically but I was like you
stars in my eyes couldn't believe this
is before Nick or Jesse had done
anything but I was like Nick Kroll I saw
his name in The Village Voice like that
was yeah the credit did the show
um that that story I don't want to we
don't have that much time left who who
got you on Best Week Ever how did that
happen so I was
um working at a sports bar on the upper
east side and a friend of mine from
college was
dating a guy who is a producer on Best
Week Ever I believe and
um she had come to my bringer shows a
bunch all throughout college and she
knew that I was sort of in a grind and I
said to her would it be okay if I got
you a VHS of my stand-up to get to him
and
um this is everything yeah I picture you
in a red striped referee's Jersey and
then an apron were you a waitress I was
a waitress for years and it was I mean
this was my bread and butter for most
like through college up until I moved to
LA same waiting tables is show business
it's Show Business little sets totally
and you like I should they should offer
waiting tables classes as a part of
acting because it's so I agree they go
hand in hand and I was I remember was
like a huge by the way there should be
classes there should be why do you have
to just figure it out over years
absolutely I have to say my first first
job was at Johnny Rockets and they sort
of give you training like it was sort of
like Burger College but like we had like
hold the tray like this yes which was
very helpful but there you're right
there should be no you slowly put it
together yeah it took me a long time I
could tell you a lot of Bennigan's
stories about moments where I failed of
course I did look at my face
I want to go to a Bennigan and have
people eat homes with them I I bet you
were an amazing okay give me Donald
Glover's mustache and I'll go Incognito
back in time and my name tags head moose
and have me wait on the table and and
you and we'll wear this is great like
Captain America and Scarlett Johansson
in our in our Incognito looks I would
love to see what I was like I bet I was
a lot for two for some people like too
much I don't I bet you had repeat
customers I want that guy again he made
us laugh my best story was we would get
a lot of kids like young teenagers that
would come in and they wouldn't didn't
tip and I would pride myself on giving
good service to the people that I knew
weren't going to tempt me and I'll never
forget this one kid was like you're the
best waiter we've ever had like that was
that was like killing wow wasn't that I
made them laugh yeah it said like I
stayed on top of it it's amazing and
they I think they did me like three
bucks or whatever it didn't matter but
that compliment matters so much and I
think he even said like we come here a
lot and people are usually like really
shitty to us and I was like but I also
have a lot of stories where I remember
an older lesbian couple wrote a letter
to me about how the line was your
reaction over the over the baked potato
soup left much to be desired it took me
like 80 cents wow I was like lady not
okay I'm of the opinion even if it sucks
you still tip them you still totally I
sometimes tip more to be like [__]
you're happy
or you're having a bad day you're having
a bad day I still remember the guy and I
know his name I won't say it because I
guess I could be sued for slander who
gave me I went Above and Beyond at this
restaurant he didn't like the meal this
was a celebrity it wasn't it wasn't it
was just a guy and I know his name I
memorized her from the credit card who
gave who wrote in zero zero on the
credit card slip because I couldn't the
restaurant wouldn't let me comp his meal
but I was like I was like I could get
you free dessert I'll get because he
didn't like it after he cleared his
plate and he left and then gave me the
finger through the window
I'm dead yeah I oh and I still I mean
for years of course leave his name in my
head that couple that wrote it was they
wrote in like shaky cursive it I was
wrong you know what they've said they
were like the the they were they were
stuck their spoon in the suit but it was
standing up like it came out like it had
been sitting under a heat lamp or
something and I was so new no waiter
school yeah that I didn't go let me get
you another one uh like soup see I could
get it myself like but I just went
that's how it comes out sometimes
I just walked away
so they were wrong but like
I'm
was an opportunity how many
opportunities do you get in a day to be
like graceful I don't mean like elegant
I mean like have yeah Grace have
understanding yes and just take one by
the way maybe don't tip maybe tell me
like you know it doesn't matter I can
see it from every side but it is a
missed opportunity to be a little Santa
Claus maybe they should have checked
themselves after the wrecking maybe
there's somewhere hosting their own
podcast going like you know when moose
waited on us I think about my shaky
cursive handwriting I hate I hate is too
strong a word but I hate that guy that
guy sucks but also what was going
through his life yeah something I try to
remember every morning is I go I'm not I
got it from father Greg Boyle who writes
these incredible books and I go I'm not
going to return hurt with hurt so like
Oh I like that he's like hurt yes
something's wrong that was it yeah
he's not having a great deal yeah like
he's trying to win it back he's losing
at the casino he's trying to win it back
at the buffet you know what I mean like
yes that's what Nate Craig had this
great yeah so he's giving you the finger
because he's been so broken and
belittled and he's so sad he's probably
afraid that he's gonna die he's his meal
like like you're his mom in that moment
like you made me money there's a meal
Mommy and it sucks why won't you pick me
up I wish I had to wear at the time to
have said that rather than crumbling in
the corner but you wrecked yourself yeah
and now we're checking yourself and
that's the way
I remember was a snowstorm on a Sunday
just checking the Timeless don't want to
don't want to go along
um it was a um so this sports bar like
during football season we'd be packed
and that was like I would bang the money
for my rent and stuff but certain weeks
if there wasn't a game it would be dead
and this day it happened to be and it
was a major snowstorm outside Noah's
there is me and the bartender my friend
was like he may be leaving this job you
have to get him this VHS whoa speak so I
asked the bar I'm like can you cover me
there's here and I went in the snowstorm
because they live not too far just
literally trudging in the snow with my
VHS tape ran it up to their apartment
and then ran back to waiting tables this
is like it was crazy stuff
and I gotta remember like I have to say
I was aware like in the moment I knew I
felt I was like I I want to tell this
story so I remember going yeah but I was
also like this is my shot like I have
there was really I had no leads I had no
I was doing stand up wherever I could I
was doing theater like in the back of
laundromats or wherever I could but
there was no I had I didn't have an
agent there was I was getting rejected
from every agency the manager that I got
from like my
um my Showcase in college had like
stopped like her whole like company went
under so there was no there was no bites
and so this was like I potentially have
a lead
um and I ran it upstairs to their
apartment and she was like okay well
hopefully you know he'll be able to pass
along and it took weeks and weeks and
weeks and I got a phone call and they
said we want to bring you in for uh yeah
and I was I know it happened but I'm
still shocked so excited because that
never happens never happens like you in
that story
we know
most of those stories end with and I
never heard yeah and if your if your
brain is nice it just sort of deletes
those stories that's true so you don't
get too disheartened oh tell the people
I love that I want to go back to that
exact moment but tell the people about
you getting mad at your parents so this
was around the same time it was probably
maybe even a week within each other
because it was at the same bar and
I was just so having so much trouble
like putting my rent together every
month and they
um and seemed like I was saying like so
hard to get someone who really believed
in me I Winston my husband was my fake
manager at the time he would pose as my
manager we got the breakdowns illegally
and he would submit me for things and
call and we would I would call as my
fake manager to get me in on auditions I
had some of my best auditions from this
fake management company but I couldn't
this is some of your best work being the
fake man Victoria darling Melissa ouch
have you ever she's amazing she's a star
do you have any uh we actually need a
guy oh yes I'm sorry
that's all we have
yeah she's the only one you need and
what was terrible about that was because
I'm such a like I don't lie because it
creates not yes there's moral uh um
implications but I'm I feel too much
guilt yeah and I worry too much that I
can't do it it will break up so part of
this was when I would go to audition I
never cheat it seems like no it's so
much effort for what seven minutes yeah
no seven minutes of sex no and then
months of like oh yeah I was
um
birthday but he Instagram that he's in
Hawaii no no I didn't go I didn't go to
his birthday I was shopping like like
for for sex I don't like sex that much
no I like being nice and relaxed like
too anxious of a person could not do it
death death and going into a dress and
then be like so who's this manager and
then it was just
I mean Panic that I had to lie to these
people that it's not a real manager
which is also so anyway hilarious so
around that same time I needed that lie
that was a good life I had to do it yeah
um my I my mom who I talked to pretty
much every day I was on it was
I couldn't afford my cell phone at the
time so I was on a pay phone I like um
this is this is signal for Payphone
Payphone stay on the Payphone
um couldn't get in for like just
circling my backstage auditions and
trying to get in and I remember saying
to my mom
this is so awful why didn't you force me
to have about like how did you let me
follow my dreams yeah you're and sobbing
sobbing to her on a payphone very New
York there's a guy with a pigeon on his
head the pigeon's on fire he's like are
you gonna be much longer
give me a second my dreams are
collapsing
my mother said how dare you let me
pursue my beauty yeah and my mom I
remember her laughing and saying it's
gonna be okay wow um but I was like and
tell Dad tell Dad the same time that I'm
mad you get to like one of those old
notes while you're away your daughter
called she's Furious not gonna talk yeah
why didn't you tell me to become a
dentist because they were very much
similar to the plan that you had of
they're like do not pick a backup career
you're going to end up doing that I was
like so you paid for an education for me
yes that is just this business where I
have nothing else to fall back on I love
it and the tape worked I'm just checking
the time if you feel me kind of going
into that Landing we're at a cruising
altitude we've begun our initial
decisions we're about to end
um which can I just say yeah since we
spoke about you said the plane I just
want to tell the listeners the first
time I met you was on a plane going to a
best week ever live tour yeah and
um you and I said this to you recently
but I need to say it for the public on
the record
kindest soul in addition to being so
funny I just remember feeling because
you know you're traveling together
so like just pure goodness oh that's so
nice that was just coming up like at me
from the seat next to me and I remember
thinking like because this business can
be so hard and awful and lonely and just
that I felt in that moment like this is
such a wonderful human and then you got
on stage and we're just so funny too but
it was just that I feel like those times
in in that struggling time when you
connect with someone that gives you a
little boost little Outpost yeah you're
a long lonely road yeah it's like that
little bit of Gatorade along the way get
you through well thank you for saying
that I as you were starting I don't know
if you're this way I'm always worried
that it's going to be like and you
wouldn't stop doing bits the whole
flight I was trying to take a nap
because I remember being on that tour
same tour and Aziz was sitting in front
of me and like MP3s had just become a
thing and oh man it's so I I just feel
for Little Pete even though he's
probably 26. but like I was asking as he
is like uh which Radiohead album should
I get like I wanted to be a cool boy and
I was like should I get Okay computer
and he was he was like clearly annoyed
he was like oh yeah man sure like trying
to sleep I'm saying I was being annoying
and I was like what about Fiona Apple
it's like whatever man
ah oh and you see I think I was that
with you no I don't I do because I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have clocked
that that my my anxiety or whatever
turns into that sort of effort that's
interesting because you were so but I
was you were working on a New Yorker
cartoon and everyone would be like
what's that yes I remember that it was
amazing that was at that time in my life
I also used to do reverse caption
contests I would be like the caption is
I'll have what she's having what's the
drawing and Jessica think Claire would
play it with me I was just like so
doe-eyed and sweet but like meaning it
was a sweet time I remember games I
still play like um pretend you're we'd
call it fake UPS like like pretend
you're asleep and then wake up I
remember and no offense to him but Judah
fried Leonard wouldn't do it look
Jessica said Claire did it it's such a
fun you know that's fun and she was like
you're smiling like do you smile when
you sleep because I was having so much
fun I'd be like I'm gonna go down
and then Judah Friedland was like no no
I'm not gonna do and I was like wow
there's like different yeah kinds of
comedians I became best friends with
Sinclair from the best week ever tour I
wish I had become best friends with her
because I I still love her to death but
like she was my Gatorade you were
certainly my Gatorade and and those
other people weren't not Gatorade yeah
no you know like attracts like and
there's a certain like we're saying our
paths are similar and I see it in you
now and I and I feel like we're
camcorder kids we're like music we're
Star Search kids would you make a horror
movie with me of course look we have
three cameras we could do it can you
imagine how fun that would be that would
be so fun I used to have all that
Halloween was when I'm sure your brother
was the same do all your blood shopping
now oh
friends
my house that um we you when everyone
was sleeping we put the horror makeup on
the kids and now as a mom I'm yeah of
course horrified yeah but that's we they
woke up in the morning faces and no one
was left oh my God
that is fantastic okay we have four
minutes here's my last question although
I feel like we could talk for nine years
I really want to do it again can I
please come back I want to talk to you
there's so much to cover okay but I I
said to Katie I was like I'm kind of
glad it's gonna have that like urgency
okay like we're gonna do it in just one
it's like hour 20 whatever perfect
um can you tell me any time in your life
where you laughed really really really
really really really hard and I always
say this it doesn't have to be a good
story like I open the door and there's
Don Knotts like it does not not that but
maybe you're with Winston maybe you're
with your brother a time in your life
where you were just crying laughing it
doesn't even have to make sense maybe
somebody fell maybe somebody farted like
these are often I I have to say it was
the it was before Winston I got together
it was the moment that I knew that I
wanted to
be with him I love it we were we were
just we were friends through college
um
and um and we were we were writing
Partners through college and then we
went a group of us from school like went
on a trip and it was right before
Halloween and we were just sitting it
was late at night we were sitting on a
bench and everyone who walked by he was
pretending that they were in a Halloween
costume but it was a half finished
Halloween costume
oh my God so and he would just like
describe what it was and then just be
like come on man finish the costume
and there was it was brilliant and it
was a great bit
for I mean we must have been for an hour
and all of us just sitting around as and
he and I remembered that like feeling
where you're just doubled over crying
laughing and that was it I was just I
told you I just didn't did I tell you I
was just in New Mexico yes earlier it
was like three hours ago and I saw a guy
dressed like a cowboy
and I was like this looks like he's in a
costume
but he was kind of too new uh-huh it's
too new it wasn't like rugged but but it
was his style it was just how he and you
know what I'm wearing a costume too but
he really looked like he was wearing
costume like he could have seamlessly
walked into a costume party that says
like costumes mandatory it had been fine
you see that's so I really envy that
because if that's if that's your thing
every day yeah you just know okay I'm
gonna giddy up and put my that's right
put my did he have a full hat oh yeah
and the Mustang he was everything wow he
pretty much had a lasso like he was that
he was inches to a lasso
if I bet TSA took his last suit like
that's why he didn't have it he did
bring it
what's the age on this dude
unageable I mean he could have been 45
to 55 I would say like Peter Pan Holmes
like Peter Pan Holmes and a callback
right at the buzzer
badge patch thank you so much thank you
this was awesome we have to watch Night
Court anything else you want to promote
oh
um just how much I love Pete Holmes and
talking to Pete Holmes all my cherry
Oscar's kids if you want to take a look
at that yeah okay Oscar's kids Oscar's
kids oscars.org it's a pediatric PayPal
um yes uh pediatric cancer not I'm sorry
not through paycheck pal but um the
website has but it's
oscarskids.org and it's a pediatric
cancer charity beautiful well thank you
pouch would you say keep it crispy it's
just a sign off it doesn't mean anything
really I want to know the history keep
it crispy
do love show videos we both just loved
show business for an hour now you asking
me to say keep it crispy yeah ignited
seven-year-old Melissa in a way that was
so so excited so thrilling my whole life
we just wanted to be asked like will you
say the kids yeah he's like are you
kidding me
I I enjoyed this more than one we've
done in a long time that's not to put
down anybody I'm just saying this was an
extra special one thank you that's how I
feel all right bye everybody bye bye
[Music]